hi everyone i'm petey and i'm here to be
your moderator
yeah good luck katie by the way
it's time to bust out the peanut butter
and oreos
because the cast of the parent trap just
reunited for the first time since
filming the 1998 movie
and they're spilling all the tea
this is so freaky
on monday director nancy myers writer
charles shire
and the stars of the hit flick dennis
quaid lindsay lohan
elaine hendrix lisa ann walter and simon
coons
all got together for a special on katie
couric's instagram
and you best believe they dished some
behind the scenes secrets
we narrowed it down how many nancy like
six did we test six
girls was it that six yeah i think
lindsay might have been the second or
third girl
up within two or three minutes we both
knew she had the part
you couldn't beat her she was just
amazing yeah lindsay who played twins
annie and hallie in the disney reboot
napped the part within minutes of her
audition
putting aside how adorable she looked
you know she had that
quality that just sort of left
up at you and pulled you in and i think
to be
a movie star and to be the lead of a
movie you need to have that connection
with the camera that
it's very present as for lindsay she
shared the secret key to playing the two
roles
come on just do it
don't panic you look great spoiler alert
it's all about the hair once you put a
wig on someone
you feel different it's a different
you're stepping out of your comfort zone
and you kind of become the other
character
and and and i feel like almost people
treated me differently when i was annie
because annie was so much nicer and how
he was
kind of like me didn't get confusing
playing your twin
um not really it was i kind of kept them
straight but it was a lot of fun
the cast also remembered their co-star
the late natasha richardson
it is very romantic well i just think
you know finally the story is
boy meets girl boy loose girl boy gets
girl but
the kids are a catalyst so it's um
it's a more romantic take on it than the
original
the actress died in 2009 after suffering
a traumatic brain
injury while skiing natasha had such an
elegance and grace and she was so
maternal to me
dennis who played natasha's ex-husband
in the film got emotional
reflecting on his friend just somebody
so
giving and uh so glad to be there and
and transmitted that joy of being able
to do what we do
and it just made everything
that much better it was a great group of
people particularly for me
dennis quaid who i did most of my scenes
with and
i love working with him the cast and
crew also weighed in on why they think
the movie still resonates over
two decades later this movie had
the fantasy of getting your parents back
together you know and so many people
so many kids come from broken homes i
did and
and i think it fulfilled that dream for
kids and for lindsay who's now
34 years old the parent trap put her on
the map
when she was just 11. i didn't feel like
i was working
it just felt like a really incredible
learning experience for me um and a lot
of fun
and and i i my parents were kind of
separating at the time when this was all
going on and
it made it a lot easier for me to
to play these characters that were
figuring it out i just felt so lucky
and really blessed by nancy and charles
like i can't there's nothing
without this movie without this i
wouldn't have gotten that acting bug how
do you not want to only act for the rest
of your life after
doing a film like this and that echoes
what little lindsay told et
back in 1998. what was the best thing
about making this movie
um just being able to be there i mean
when i was younger i would like
sit down and pray every night so that i
could be in a movie and
it's finally come true